I've got carpet in my bathroom and the
place we're staying I've got carpet in
the in the toilet I'm not a fan of that
like what if I miss not that I'm going
to but if I am I'm a super so are you
yeah do you guys sit when you every now
and then the bidets are so warm oh they
are warm yeah so it's my job to clean
the toilet in my house and I don't want
to do the work oh so I only have to
clean it if uh if if it's my toilet so
me and Cindy have both of our own
toilets yes we just have cleaners come
every once in a while
L.A lifestyle man
I'm more saikuno is one of us yeah he
was one of the real ones it helps I mean
yeah streamers be like yeah because like
you know I've heard about stream houses
sometimes just being an absolute [__]
mess just oh you guys are alive like
most thousands of the day I do think the
standards have gone up really I'm sorry
super long but a lot of my friends have
been streaming for a long time okay they
have those gamer houses yeah they were
really really dank not in a good way
yeah yeah I feel like the standards gone
up these days oh okay people actually
taking care of them
every single quote-unquote streamer
house has been the most excessive thing
ever seen in my life yeah I do think it
partially just because streamers make
more money than before maybe and they
have more cleaners they're necessarily
cleaner themselves but they can afford
someone and help them with it yeah and I
think like security over there needs to
be so much tighter as well oh yeah
because I guess like we don't have any
fear of being no not dogs but at least
like swatted or [__] like that you know
I would probably be more difficult too
yeah how the [__] are you going to tell
the Japanese police to come to my house
or something you know what I mean it's
like all right good luck yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah they're like this is the
address and they look at the address
it's like oh [__]
anybody who knows no no no this is not a
challenge but it's a nice layer of added
security where you're like all right you
gotta first of all you gotta translate
this address into Japanese and then
you've got to say it and then you've got
to oh yeah
which they don't do [__] well it's
another thing about like a lot of
Americans friends I've like I have have
talked about having that car broken into
and I don't know if you guys have ever
that happens a lot yeah that's such a
weird thinks me because I've never had
even in England like my car getting
broken into no yeah have you no never
yeah I just I just like when when I when
I went to America to uh meet my cousin
she was like make sure there is nothing
on the back seats like no phones yeah
don't show off anything nice yeah you
got a nice bag don't put it there yeah
gotta put it in the trunk maybe even
when you're just parking at the grocery
store or something there's always
something I I would even also recommend
just don't leave anything expensive out
yeah because people definitely just
smack the windows
video I had a friend who was living in
San Francisco oh that's at the capital
of Carl
no she told me one day yeah I just went
to uh went to go to work and uh I got to
my car and uh there was just a guy in
there and there was just a guy sleeping
in there absolutely sleeping yes
sleeping in the car that's crazier than
I've heard of I've robbed I would have
easily believed that yeah that's crazy
maybe he like tried to like you know hot
wire the car and he's like this isn't
working
yeah
yeah yeah it's uh absolutely like
different kind of environment for me
yeah what do you think of Japanese food
so far because you must get it quite a
lot in California already right
really really good here
um and it's much less expensive I think
so there's a Japanese curry place I like
in California
um and I think for the curry like
literally just the plate of curry with
Meats like regular plates yeah it's like
20 something dollars what it's pretty
expensive but I like it and there aren't
that many of them so I'm like I get it
sometimes and then here we went to a
place that was literally better and I
think it was seven dollars
oh no it was a different one I don't
even know the name of it actually go go
Curry it's just like a small one oh okay
it's just a local one yeah much better
is seven dollars and they do like you
choose your size it's the same price no
matter what which is crazy yeah I'm
thinking of Cocoa Beach yeah yeah a
little extra for something yeah yeah
there are some things where when they
say choose your size most most of the
time it's just the amount of rice that
you have
um but if you have like katsu or some
other toppings on it then that comes
like extra but even then it's like not
that much yes compared to 20 bucks
yeah it's a lot nicer yeah yeah Curry's
just like the cheap food here you know
it's yeah
Japanese Curry specifically Japanese
currency I think Indian curry is way
better I think Union Curry is really
good too it depends on the mood better
yeah
it's both but like it's you know I I
have the cravings for like Japanese
Curry sometimes because it is different
right and it's like not to say one is
better than the other but like it's it's
this uh it's a safe option you know it's
the most inoffensive Curry you could
have out of all like the World Cup it's
like if you took into Curry like how to
make less flavor and less harsh
it's not all more like acceptable for a
light palette even though it's like
compared to other Foods it's still heavy
but compared to other curries I mean I'm
gonna be patriotic for a second Thai
curry [__] oh wait yeah taiku is one
of the best two yeah I feel like I just
like any kind of cream
who doesn't like Curry it's so good it's
a [__] Hardware yeah to have a bad
carry yeah exactly you know in the UK
Curry is the national dish did you know
that
is that delicious yeah legit I've never
had UK is it called UK Curry is that
it's uh the national dish of UK is
actually chicken tikka masala I don't
know if you've had that before I have
but how how did that because it's not
from India it's from Scotland yeah it's
from Scotland
I've only had it at Indian places yeah
it's so it's like a Westerner kind of
thing but it was made by like some
people in Scotland yeah wow it's like
the equivalent that's I didn't know that
it's like
seriously I can't tell if you are gonna
trick them into genuinely no it's gonna
go to someone and be like you know
chicken tikka masala's from Scotland and
someone's gonna think
I'm 100 sure it is it's definitely not
Indian it's like the equivalent of
calling uh you know uh sweet and sour
chicken or orange chicken Chinese food
right because right it is kind of based
on Chinese Cantonese dishes but it was
you know that's part of like you know
that specific dish was invented and I
believe America
yeah so you can't get it in most if you
go to China you can't get in most
Chinese places they'll be like what the
hell's sweet and sour chicken yeah most
likely if you go to a pub uh most of
them will give Curry like a little serve
it if you want so if I want to get the
best chicken Tikko Masala I gotta go to
Scotland no no no no no no no no no
that's what I thought you were about to
do no no I'm just saying like we it's
just like it's weird how I think Curry
is uh regardless of where you are in the
world everyone [__] loves just soup
and meat kind of combined with starch
yeah with a little bit of either potato
or rice yeah yeah there's some kind of
starch to go with it it's probably one
of my favorite things yeah it's like I
don't think like on the on the tier of
like you know Indian curries chicken
tikka masala is like you know bottom
tier for me you know there are better
carriers you can get you got to try
Hokkaido soup curry oh that's that's the
[__] yeah how are you with spicy food I
like spicy food yeah okay okay okay
you know I've met enough people that are
just like I like spicy food and then and
then I always have to ask like how spicy
can you go you know I'm trying this
like okay what's is there we've done the
hot ones challenge okay hot ones
challenge that's something you had any
of those hot sauces I think I've had
some of them okay and
I think there's one called the bomb or
something yeah okay that was like the
max level that I wasn't just absolutely
suffering on
um and I think it was the third hottest
in in the set we bought like a yeah okay
okay it's pretty good though that's
pretty good yeah absolute Max but I
still would go less than that if I
wanted to be happy okay but that was the
max where I'm like all right I just
wouldn't eat it unless I'm like doing
some kind of challenge or yeah
um that's the Vietnamese blood in you
man
it's in your bloodline so yeah if you
can handle like spicy food Hokkaido soup
curry they just like load this [__] up
with spices and sometimes you can get it
like really really spicy a little bit
Moder as well if you can't you know if
you can't handle that even mild it's
[__] awesome okay yeah it's just
Curry but soup
that's sort of like
it's similar consistency yeah yeah you
like udon yeah
is Udon bad I like a good one they like
udon I don't I'm thinking udon's too
thick ramen's way better I think yeah it
doesn't like it thick don't like it
thick yeah interesting have you had a
any Ramen or any other kinds of noodles
aside from mood on we actually okay this
is absolutely wild but we so the first
foods you think of when going to Japan
at least for me it's probably like Curry
Ramen um and sushi sushi yup uh we
haven't had any sushi because Hassan
just doesn't eat seafood yep uh we're
gonna try and go at some point all right
we also haven't gone to any ramen places
because usually when it sounds like
you'll go like later at night or
something or whatever and we've been so
tired that we just haven't done it so
we've been here for only for a few days
right but we just haven't done like two
of the three things I feel like they're
the instant things you think of when you
go right right so yeah I mean in terms
of sushi I don't know I don't know if
this is a hot take or not but I don't
think Sushi is like people have this
idea that they go to the Japan they go
to a local sushi place and it's just
gonna be like God like like nothing
they've ever tasted before but I think
you get a little bit of an improvement
but not as much as a lot of people think
you get I think it depends on the price
point all right like in terms of like
just like regular can be uh like uh
conveyor belt Sushi like I I say there's
like a slight increase like you're
talking about but like if you want like
the the [__] that will change your life
then you need to be paying like
egregious amounts of money for I mean
it's out and even expensive yeah and
even then it's like if you're not that
well versed in sushi you're probably not
going to taste the difference yeah I
have not had like life-changing Sushi
even at some like really really
expensive like you know like Posh Sushi
chains right
um there's a there's a slight increase
but you know in my mind there's only so
many ways you can there's only so many
ways you can present fish uh you know
you can use fish Wasabi rice and vinegar
right and you you can play around with
the ratio but there's only so much you
can do to get that as good as it can
possible crying right now yeah yeah your
work is [__]
and I say this as someone who [__]
loves Sushi the thing I love about
Japanese sushi is that you can get
[__] amazing sushi for a good price
if you want to get sushi outside of
Japan you have to pay like a [__]
well yeah that's where I think Japan
Sushi's at its best is that it's not
that like somehow the fish is magically
better yeah I just think that at a at an
affordable price point that's much
higher quality than what you would get
like it's in the UK you could buy you go
to the supermarket and get a sushi tray
yeah and it was like you'd you'd bite
into the prawn or the shrimp and it
would like bounce back like your teeth
wouldn't bounce it and they'll be like
that aftertaste sometimes yeah and
salmon would be tough yeah and you're
like damn here it's like it doesn't
matter where I get salmon it's like it's
always good yeah even though it's not
even from Japan yeah and I guess if you
compare it to like a lot of like
American restaurants where you can get
sushi there it's like I think the
biggest benefit is that you pay less for
more fish right so it's like the cuts
are bigger and also it's like fresher I
guess if you can like taste the
difference but like I think that's like
the biggest selling point it's like oh I
get this much fish felt like half the
price that I can get in the US okay
that's that's pretty life-changing I
feel like everything's just been less
expensive like a clothing especially
compared to California oh you're in
California
yeah it's like um what's it called yeah
the food is cheaper the clothing even is
I think uh March bought a jacket right a
pretty nice jacket and it was like
I think it was like almost 30 off
basically just because of the conversion
rate right which is crazy I was like I
can't believe I feel like I should buy
everything I can everything's basically
on sale just just purely because yeah
it's like really really bad for Japan
right now which is great if you're
coming to visit uh as a foreigner yeah
because you everything's on discount
like 30 or something like that like it's
0.7 for every uh like around 0.7 I mean
yeah
yeah it used to be a lot more
um but yeah since Japan closed off this
country for so long the kind of the
conversion rate just oh that's why
foreigners love Japan right it makes
them feel way more richer yeah they used
to be closer a lot closer it used to be
like 100 yen was nearly a dollar yeah
yeah um and it's way easier to convert
stuff but now it's like I don't [__]
know I use a lot of cash here uh they do
yeah yeah and I my wallet doesn't have a
coin oh I have a coin purse and I just
don't know what to do with the coins
I've been I've been giving all my coins
to March because I'm like I don't know
what I can't just keep all these coins
in my pocket so right I'm like here
here's all the coins use them somewhere
um because I I don't know how to hold
all these coins the craziest thing is
when you you have like a certain amount
of coins and I guess there's a hundred
coins right you give them the coin
you're like finally I'm getting rid of
these coins they give you your change
and you get more coins back and I'm like
I'm trying to get rid of the coins but
now I got four coins from my 1 100 coin
yeah and it's crazy because you can buy
stuff for less than a dollar yeah like
in the US it's like you can't buy
anything for a dollar yeah then you go
to the 90 you go to the one dollar store
and they have things that cost more than
a dollar it's crazy went to the one
dollar store and I was like oh this
looks nice it's like twelve dollars I
was like why is it called the one dollar
store I will say there's nothing more
satisfying than paying for like you go
to a combini and you pay for the amount
you that you buy for the exact change
yeah and just getting rid of all that
change I remember like when I first
moved to Japan I was super like worried
and anxious about like holding up a line
and just like getting the perfect change
but but like after a year after a year
of living here I'm like no you can wait
I'm going to get rid of all of the coins
yeah I've literally like Min maxed the
amount of change I get so I get like the
least amount of change every time I go
to the economy I also like that there's
a five dollar coin I think that's nice I
don't want I don't want one dollar bills
that's so much effort and five dollar
bills so it's nice to have all the bills
be like high denominate denominations
denominations yeah yeah uh it's just
nice I like that and the coin is feels
powerful
yeah sure